la tortuga y la liebre están compitiendo
para ver quién puede correr 100 pies en
la menor cantidad de tiempo sus
posiciones en pies como función del
tiempo en segundos tdt y hdt
respectivamente están graficadas abajo
entonces tdt es la posición de la
tortuga en función del tiempo y está en
pies y hdt es la posición de la liebre
cuál es el significado de la razón de
cambio de dt en el intervalo en donde t
es mayor que 0 y menor que 20 así que te
dé te estamos diciendo que la tortuga
está aquí esta es la función tdt esta
línea azul y parece que se está moviendo
a una razón de cambio constante la
pendiente de esta línea es constante así
que veamos cuál es esta razón de cambio
si empezamos podemos empezar desde la
posición de inicio cuando pasa a un
segundo cada división en eje horizontal
es un segundo es 1 2 3 4 5 así que cada
vez que pasa a un segundo parece parece
que y tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos
aquí al principio podemos decir o puede
que haya avanzado un pie tenemos que ser
cuidadosos sobre qué es lo que estas
divisiones representan vemos que estas
divisiones representan
25 pies así que cada vez que pasa un
segundo él se mueve adelante por cinco
pies pasa otro segundo y se mueve
adelante otros cinco pies
entonces parece que la tortuga
thor
puga
la razón de la tortuga
de la tortuga la razón de la distancia
con respecto al tiempo es 5
por cada segundo
entonces veamos cuál de nuestras
opciones empata con eso y eso debe ser
en el intervalo entero el intervalo
comienza aquí en 0 y el 20 está aquí
y parece que tiene una razón constante
tiene una pendiente constante con la
misma inclinación de la línea todo el
tiempo todo el camino hasta que t es
igual a 20
entonces la primera opción es que la
tortuga camina a 5 pies por segundo todo
el tiempo y esto parece correcto ya que
la razón de la tortuga es igual a 5 pies
por segundo de manera constante este
camino puede ser entendible 5 pies por
segundo es una buena velocidad
especialmente para una tortuga así que
iremos por ésta
también vamos a revisar las otras por
diversión para ver qué tan ciertas son o
cómo pueden ser aplicadas a este
problema
la liebre deja de moverse después de
cinco segundos así que veamos este es el
tiempo cero aquí son cinco segundos si
buscamos si buscamos la posición de la
liebre después de cinco segundos
entonces después de cinco segundos
después de que el tiempo es igual a
cinco segundos de hecho se ve como la
posición de la liebre la liebre está
solo sentada allí en los 90 pies en la
línea que marca los 90 pies
y no hay ningún movimiento la razón del
cambio de la posición con respecto al
tiempo para la liebre en esta posición
es 0 así que esto es correcto solamente
que no aplica a la pregunta no es el
significado de la razón de cambio de tdt
en este intervalo esto es htc
la liebre corre a una velocidad de 18
pies por segundo por los primeros 5
segundos
veamos si esto es cierto por los
primeros 5 segundos
estos son cinco segundos pasando la
liebre es capaz de recorrer una
distancia la liebre es capaz de recorrer
una distancia de 90 pies
entonces la liebre es capaz de recorrer
90 pies en 5 segundos para los primeros
cinco segundos primeros
segundos la liebre
la razón
de la liebre es
90 pies
podemos decir que la razón de cambio
promedio es 90 pies en
5 segundos y 90 dividido entre 5 es
igual a 18 pies por segundo así que una
vez más este tercer enunciado es cierto
solamente que no aplica para tdt no está
haciendo referencia a la pregunta y la
cuarta opción es la liebre gana la
carrera ahora ganar la carrera es llegar
a los 100 pies en la menor cantidad de
tiempo aquí son los 100 pies así que
veamos parece que solo la tortuga llega
a este punto a los 20 segundos la
tortuga llega a la marca de los 100 pies
la liebre se queda dando vueltas o
comiendo una manzana o algo a los 90
pies así que esto es en realidad falso
la tortuga gana la carrera entonces
definitivamente escogemos la primera
opción